foreign
[Music]
we will share some best practices on how
to keep your Google kubernetes engine or
gke clusters up to date and how to
choose an upgrade strategy that is best
suited for your needs and maximize the
availability and reliability of your gke
environments first we recommend that you
have multiple gke environments to
minimize risk and unwanted downtime by
allowing you to test upgrades on a
staging environment before upgrading the
production environment
the production environment is mainly
used for serving live traffic to end
users and Mission critical business
applications
staging environment is where you test
changes from the new gke version to make
sure that everything is working as
expected before updating the production
environment
test environment is used to run
performance benchmarks test and QA
workloads against the same version which
you want to run in production
development environment is where you
carry your active deployment with the
same version that is running in your
production environment
next be aware that kubernetes releases
updates on a regular basis
those updates include bug fixes security
patches and introducing new features
gke allows you to incorporate kubernetes
updates into your clusters automatically
using gke release channels and the auto
upgrade feature
gka release Channel offers you the
ability to balance between stability and
a feature set of the version deployed in
a cluster
it is recommended to enroll your cluster
in an appropriate release channel to
allow Google to upgrade your cluster and
its notebooks automatically
however you can control the timing and
scope of the upgrades using maintenance
windows and exclusions that fit your
business needs
to keep your clusters up to date with
the latest gke version and kubernetes
updates Google recommends to use the
stable or regular channel to prioritize
the stability of your production
workloads and use the same channel as
production in staging environment to
ensure your tests are indicative of the
version your production will be upgraded
to
keep in mind that Google publishes the
information about new updates on the gke
release notes page check the section for
your clusters release channel to get
detailed information about the latest
update
each release Channel offers a default
gke version which is used for auto
upgrades
new patch releases become available at
least one week before turning into the
default version and new minor releases
will become available at least four
weeks before turning into the default
option
once a new version is available we
recommend that you test it in a staging
environments and upgrade your production
environments before that version becomes
the default one
this approach will give you more time
for testing and allow more control over
the production environment
gke will skip Auto upgrade if your
clusters were already upgraded manually
as mentioned earlier you can create a
maintenance window that will ensure that
the gke upgrades are performed during
off-peak business hours
let me walk you through step by step how
you can set up a maintenance window
first log into your Google Cloud console
then hand over to kubernetes engine and
select clusters
select the desired cluster and scroll
down to automation
under this section enable the
maintenance window by simply checking
the Box
here you can either select the weekly
editor which allows you to select the
days of the week on which the
maintenance will occur
or you can select the custom editor
option which allows you to pick the
start and end times for your maintenance
in our example we will choose the weekly
editor and set Sunday as the day when
the maintenance will occur click on Save
changes
excellent the maintenance window has
been created successfully
finally let's discuss a couple of
different strategies you can use with
your gke clusters
search upgrades in this strategy the
nodes are upgraded in a rolling window
you can control how many nodes can be
upgraded at once and how disruptive
upgrades are to the workloads
blue green upgrades this strategy will
keep your existing notes available for
rollback while the workloads are
validated on the new node configuration
for more information about each of these
strategies check out these documents
and to get more information on best
practices for upgrading gke clusters
refer to this document thank you for
watching